everyone is Peter Brown here with a
gamespot news update today during a
press event at GDC 2015 sony announced a
brand new prototype for the revere
headset Morpheus the new Morpheus
prototype features nine tracking LEDs
which sony says should make positional
tracking more accurate a new prototype
which features a 5.7 inch screen also
supports a hundred-degree field-of-view
and three-hundred-and-sixty-degree
tracking the latest model sports in 1920
by RGB x 1080 oled display meaning all
pixels have RGB subpixels this enables
low persistence removing motion blur
caused by the LCD screen from the
original prototype the newest Morpheus
prototype also features 120 Hertz
refresh rate which is double that
compared to the first edition pricing
for the consumer model of Morpheus was
not announced sony also confirmed it
will show more games for the device at
e3 in june and during other industry
events i had a chance to look at
Morpheus earlier today and I'll be
providing my impressions of it soon so
stay tuned to gamespot com for more GC
coverage and info on Sony's Morpheus